you did a podcast with two screenwriters
any takeaways from that it was
interesting so the the one woman was
very nervous one of the screenwriters
was very nervous about pitching she
always felt self-conscious and you know
what should I do what are the tips that
I need so I gave a lot of tips on on how
to really interact with your audience it
doesn't really matter who your audience
is but especially in in any kind of
emotional artistic endeavor it's about
telling that story from a place of heart
how does it matter to you and to go in
and to say so this is one of the things
I tell my speakers and I believe I said
it on the podcast but if I didn't this
is a bonus the story is never about you
it's about your North Star so you need
to identify that early on you know when
I sit down with a speaker that's what we
do early on you know where do you want
to leave the audience what's the one
idea that you want them to think about
or act upon when they leave the theatre
what is it we want them to share or do
and when they start to get nervous the
speaker as they often do that's a sign
that their ego is taking over and so the
way I read directed is to say hey this
isn't about you this is about the
message that you have that one thing
that we identified at the end that you
want them to walk away with and think
about or act upon or share and so when
you start to feel nervous you say you
know what I have something that's bigger
than me it's greater than me I'm on a
mission and I'm there to follow that
North Star and so for Amy we identified
that love was her mission for her TED
talk and that she needed to share that
people needed to know that you can be
loved and that you should love it's
never said in the talk but that was what
I'd say when you what is your message
she'd be loved and she was amazing that
way she embraced everything and and so
when you go to pitch that takes the
pressure off of you because it's the
story what is your storyline why did you
write the
characters why did you do any of this
right uh is it social justice you know
what is it that you want to know and
this is it women's issues LGBTQ what is
it that you want us to know about these
characters and that's what I love about
life right now - is that the voices that
have not had the stage are now starting
to have the stage but their messages are
universal they're emotional and they're
what we've all been through and when you
hit those emotional touch points you can
really spark your audience's imagination
feeling it and then and then thinking
about all the possibilities so that's
what I would want for people who are
going in to pitch anything but
especially TV or film to go in and to
always know their North Star what is the
one thing you want that audience to know
about what you're working on what you
care about this baby and if you don't
have anything that is you feel like it's
not totally hitting the mark tell a
personal story right and and when you
tell that personal story it says so much
more than facts and figures could ever
say because it tells you the layers of
you and it lets people walk away and go
wow I never looked at it that way and
that applies to my life - so you create
this connection but again that's I
believe that's one of the things that
I've talked about in this podcast to get
over the fear some people's fears are so
deep I mean they'll ask me should I take
medication you know should I take an
antidepressant seriously and I'm I'm
miss natural like you know I don't I
really like should I take this cold
medicine I don't know that much of a
freak right I'm a supplement girl
so I say take magnesium be careful with
meditation before you speak because
meditation can really bring you into
this beautiful Zen place but you need a
little bit of that energy a little bit
of that angst on the stage to keep you
sort of percolating up there and to
share that feeling you need
to take that energy and if the
meditation can make you flat and so you
have to strike that balance and I had a
speaker who meditated once and I was
like oh no no it's name and what but but
and I'm all for meditation but you early
in the morning don't do it like you know
15 minutes before you're onstage and so
what about too much coffee though
because sometimes coffee can be good I
know this seems like so trivial but
don't know it actually can really shift
and how you interact with people you're
perceived and it could be that you've
just had a great cup of like expresso
and people like wow you're intense but
you're just like wow I just had this
thing and you think yeah everything's
crystal clear and wonderful but do you
ever talk about caffeine moderation I do
I do so what we're kind of like camels I
tell all of my speakers the day before I
want you to drink eight glasses of water
okay all throughout the day at least
eight full size glasses and then that
way you'll be properly hydrated for the
next day the day that you speak because
we rarely drink the amount of water
we're supposed to drink the day of right
because we're visiting we're busy we're
traveling or whatever it is or backstage
so hydrate hydrate hydrate
if you drink caffeine just drink the
same amount that you always drink and I
say that speaking is a sport so I want
you to stretch out like an athlete and I
want you to eat light so avoid the carbs
I want you to be slightly hungry when
you deliver it because that also helps
with the clarity of the mind the carbs
can kind of bring you down a little bit
you can have that afterwards is your
reward but before you know really think
light think a little piece of protein a
little bit of veggies just something
really crisp and clean and then you'll
be you'll deliver your synapses a fire a
lot better and don't over caffeinate if
you drink one cup of coffee in the
morning or
cup of tea stick to that no more no less
because other otherwise do your point we
get excited and we're like oh there's no
water man I'll just drink some more tea
or some more coffee and then that will
tighten the vocal cords and dry them out
and you don't want that you want to keep
those vocal cords nice and warm and and
happy and water is the thing that will
do that also
herbal tea can drive up dry out your
throat so be careful of the herbal tea
but so it's not a trivial question I'm
kind of a maniac about it and then the
stretching is important too because we
get tight in the neck and we get tired
in the lower back especially because
we're probably rehearsing the days
before and even maybe that morning so
stretch it out and remember to breathe
as I say to my speakers if you don't
breathe ya can't smile and if you don't
smile how will the audience know you're
having fun so always remember to breathe
when you're when you're working on all
of these just that we're cursing and
then the actual day and the pausing will
help you do that and I work with my so I
take my speakers we we write the story
when when they're going to the stage we
write the story we transfer that story
and we begin to build slides so it's
actually more like a video they click on
emotional words so they don't click it
an end of a sentence or idea they click
on emotional words so the image and the
words as the story crescendos the image
and the words marry to each other so
they really stick with the audience so
it's very deliberate I have to work with
my speakers with this technique all the
way through so they can deliver and the
pauses are as important as the vocal
variation as the way they move and may
manage the stage what are some of those
emotional words well it really depends
on on there is a particular word it
usually is the feeling and so if there's
a I'm trying to think of in some of my
talks well in sharra says talk rap on
trial she talks about being an expert
witness and at this particular part of
the story she says
as the expert witness and she is the
there's a lawyer there in front of her
who's grilling her and she has said you
know the width the the the evidence will
prove the the person who's on trial this
rap music artist he's gonna get off
because the evidence is so clear that
you know he didn't do this that he's not
guilty
and when she's presented all of her
evidence and this is the first time
she's ever been an expert witness she's
and she's unbelievable this woman the
way she she delivers ideas crisp and
clear and concise and so in the story
she's just told the jury why that he
should be you know let go and the lawyer
walks up to her and says I can't
remember exactly what he says but he
slams down a pistol on the the stand in
front of her and says oh really is this
what you consider you know and I he and
then the audience sees the gun the jury
sees the gun they see that woman and so
when we click for that when she says and
he slant we click for a picture of a
pistol up close and personal and boom
you know and so she really drives home
that point and she says emotions Trump
logic every time hmm and we see that gun
up there when we feel it so it really
the story tells me where the images go
okay so that's not particularly no it's
really yeah thank you for asking to
clarify that but it's really the the
story is the foundation that tells me oh
my gosh this needs an image so and not
as much text it does that take away text
takes away because the audience doesn't
know whether to read or listen to you so
you have to be very deliberate in your
top in the way you use text so again in
sharra says talk there's a part where
she talks about about guns
and about rappers so if this was a white
rapper who was on trial it would be very
different and so we actually put white
rapper plus gun equals he's gone astray
right so I needed to do that I came up
with this idea I was like how do we
visually show this it wasn't the best
way but it's all we had right and then
we showed black rapper plus gun equals a
thug destined for prison and so to see
those words on there and you can
actually hear the audience gasp because
the difference is startling and you know
it can be a very powerful thing but we
animated those words so they couldn't
read ahead right we spoon-feed the
audience the text as we need otherwise
they'll read ahead and that will take
them out of the story so that's how I
that's why and how I don't use text very
often and I if I use it I use it very
very strategically and sparingly you
know when you're about to go into pitch
or you have to give the speech you're
gonna do an audition whatever it is
there's the nerves and I think there's
some people that want to just be alone
with the material and not speak to
anybody because they're so like I've
gotta get this right I've got to get
this right and then there's others that
they're just chatting away and maybe
that's part of their process it makes
them less nervous what do you think Wow
as a kind of an ambivert I don't know I
don't trust those people are talking
away beforehand hi I am just like a
worrier right so I worry about my own
speeches uh I so I gave it to talk and
that was and I did the TED talk because
I was putting my speakers through all
these paces but I'd never tried them
myself so I tried the paces and I
suffered oh did I suffer from just not
ever doing I was like oh I called each
one of my speakers I said will you
forgive me for everything I've ever done
to you they're laughing oh but because
the process is difficult right it's it's
a lot but in the end it's the thing that
keeps you moving forward but I can't
and meeting your mark and crossing over
the finish line I can't imagine having
chatted any with anyone beforehand right
I mean that's one of the things in terms
of speakers to me some of the most
interesting speakers are either
introverts or ambivert s-- because
there's an inner world right that's what
speaking is it's toggling between this
inner world and outer world that so
writing is and so I find that the the
introverts the the amber verts tend to
be more interworld reflective and that's
also very needed for an audience that
doesn't always have a lot of time to
take their own time to reflect and I
think that that needs a little bit of
time alone or with a coach just sort of
working on things beforehand or even the
day like the hour of because it's
sometimes I've been of a different
school of thought if I have to do
something that I'm very nervous about it
actually can help me sometimes to
converse with others in the waiting room
but then other times it spreads my
energy too thin and then I'm not focused
so I really have to kind of pick and
choose when I do that because I'm
probably more of the introvert class but
just you know I just wondered if there
was because you know there's always the
school thought well that actor or that
musician whatever they they hang out in
the back
they don't come to set they're not you
know but maybe that's part of their
process because there's a you know real
backlashes well you they don't want to
be part of the group maybe that's how
they kind of preserve their their who
they are their character their energy
and I just wondered if you had thoughts
on I I feel those people yeah because I
don't have an infinite amount of energy
and you know extroverts will take the
energy from the room and use it right so
it's their fuel my husband's an
extrovert and and he's fueled by people
and I'm fueled by people in a certain
way to a certain point that makes sense
they differ all those introverts out
there it does extroverts and that
doesn't mean that I don't love people
and don't enjoy being with them I
thoroughly do but I have
cutoff point absolutely an expiration
point where I'm like okay I gotta go
recharge my batteries with the cats over
there where it's quiet or hiking or
hiking right exactly I love the outdoors
and that's a really great restorative
thing to do the beach just go walk on
the beach I mean so I need that I need
that quiet time and that reflective time
to really process it all because I'm
also having very deep conversations like
probably therapy deep right but but so
it doesn't mean that there's one right
way or one wrong way it's really just
you have to touch base with you and say
how am I feeling right now did I overdo
it is that was that too much and it
depends on the type of speech you're
giving so if you're giving a speech
where you have to memorize everything
and all my speakers have to the when
they're the shorter speeches they have
to memorize everything when they're the
longer speeches so someone my speakers
speak for an hour I have them craft the
open and craft the clothes because as I
say to them speeches are like flying you
know takeoff and landings of the most
dangerous so you got to pay attention so
I really get them to crack that open and
that close which are very short but then
they got to know the middle and some of
my speakers actually will memorize not
verbatim but darn near an entire hour so
I have some incredible speakers that are
just able to do that very gifted so it
really depends if you're giving a
PowerPoint presentation that's a whole
different thing that's again you might
have a messaging craft for the beginning
and a message that you want to leave a
heartfelt message you want to leave at
the end and then in the middle you just
sort of follow the the trail of of your
slides
that'll prompt you when you see them and
that's what I do with my speakers too
when they have slides I say like that
let the image the slide be your guide it
will remember and remind you what you're
supposed to be saying here and it does
it's amazing that way now think about
someone like Steve Jobs I mean this is
off topic and if we don't want to yeah
but Steve Jobs was just such a great I
mean you just kind of hung on his every
word what when he gave a speech I know
Larry Ellison is similar from some of
the speeches I've watched and I'm not
even in that world but I just find that
he'd the way he delivers a story the way
he is timing different different people
really do have like this captivating
almost like rock star quality that you
want to hang on their every word even if
you're not interested in the subject
matter and I'm not even sure if is that
something someone's born with or do they
learn it over time I'm of the firm
believer under the firm belief of the
fact that I think that we all inherently
have it it's just that some of us dig
for it some of it it comes eat more
easily than others some of us have had
traumas that keep it buried I've had
speakers that I just couldn't get to be
natural and I worked and worked and
worked with them to really just be more
present when I had conversations but
they were lovely and wonderful but the
minute they got on stage it was like
child star and then you know so there
became a lack of trust in themselves
that they weren't enough I think that's
probably the best message I can have and
I believe that when you look like your
conversational like a Steve Jobs or
Larry Ellison or any of the speakers
that are just you want to say well look
can we meet for a tea and talk right I'm
not even gonna pitch you right exactly
there's somebody here more about it what
other sort what other stories you got
for me cuz they're really good and I'm
engaged let's go right right um they've
worked at that and they really really
really enjoy it I mean that's the gift
of storytelling for me this sense of
wonder I really love to hear people's
stories and I wonder what it was it's
like to be them right I can never be
them but I wonder what it's like to be
them and how much I see when they share
these stories how much we have in common
so for me I believe were all gifted now
how many of us use the gift and do the
hard work that it takes to look like a
Steve Jobs one day he might have started
that practice when he was young right he
other people may have had to cover it up
with the life circumstances right but it
was important to him I didn't know him
but I can tell you that if you sat down
with him he would tell you that it was
important and he saw the he felt more
than he saw he felt the power of story
and what it could do for not only
himself but the people around him how it
can motivate and inspire them and tear
them down right so it really he was
strategic and when you tell stories for
good you can move mountains you truly
truly can and again the audience is
hungry for it they need it the audience
mean me you and everyone we feel
isolated and more alone than ever before
it doesn't matter that we have devices
and ways to connect we're lonely because
we're not feeling what we need to be
feeling seeing a picture or reading a
post that's nice and all but to sit down
with you here today and really connect
and to hear all your beautiful
thoughtful questions and all the love
that you put into film courage thank you
you're welcome
I mean that from the bottom of my heart
you've been my inspiration and watching
this channel has been like oh my god
drove all the way to Northern California
and listen to the ken oh yeah uh-huh oh
my god thank you you're welcome
but they're so thoughtful these
questions and so insightful and you've
done a lot of personal work to get there
thank you you have and that allows me to
be able to I say oh kindred spirit and
we're able to talk to each other because
I know that you know and that you
understand it doesn't mean that when
we're talking to other people who don't
understand that we can't still have a
conversation with them they need us even
more right
because they then we aren't alone right
we're filling ourselves up from the
inside and when we can do that we can
then teach others how to do that as well
to see the best in themselves and that's
what film courage does for me seeing
that knowing I'm not alone when I'm
scared out of my mind to go to the next
step of writing right and experimenting
for all the reasons you could say oh I'm
this or a matter no how could I be no
you're not alone just watch a video and
you'll hear somebody else with that
through that - oh okay great
so you know thank you yeah that's why
you know David's idea for the blog its
own courage and then we started doing
the podcast and he puts equal amount of
time into the questions as well but that
was why we wanted to do it is we felt a
connection as well hearing other
people's stories and you're right it's
it's you know you can have Twitter
streams and all these great videos and
it's not the same as seeing someone face
to face and just hearing a story yeah
without judging right just sitting down
and hearing a real story because we're
hearing so many manufactured stories and
I'm hearing you know the word narrative
being tossed around and hijacked in ways
that I don't really appreciate
especially in the corporate world
because they're saying that they're
telling stories but stories really
they're about revealing something that
you're a little bit afraid to reveal to
say you know what this took me a long
time to get here and I'm embarrassed to
tell you that I still make these
mistakes you know what I do and just by
telling that telling the story of of
your life of a place you tripped up and
it's genuine you're not telling it
because you are looking for a strategy
to get somebody to do something like a
chess piece you're doing it because you
really want to let people know you're
not alone life is an existential journey
and none of us are going to come
and unscathed right so to know that you
fell and skinned your knee - you did I
did - oh my gosh I didn't see that step
right
that's what story does and that's my
purpose in the world through story
that's my Northstars to let the the
people around know they're not alone and
that please sit down and have heartfelt
conversations with the people that you
care about maybe strangers you don't
even know you know we're each other's
angels but we got to take the time - and
the risk of vulnerability to start - to
share and say wow I'm so glad that you
crossed my path
today
you